this is my favorite part every cuz I
asked John I was like who was filming
her he's like it's usually me yeah it's
always awesome if you're making fun of
him I know I know people always think we
have a third party filming us for these
things I mean oh we just live together
and he films me I forced him to do it
um but honestly that he all my awards
are so silly usually and this baby to
baby one meant the world to me so it was
it was fun to move around his awards he
had enough up yes like I get I have like
a Victoria's Secret best hair hottest
chip award and better sake I would love
your award
I got like 60 for a mic or some kind of
late like way back in the hundred like
I'm like for like Maxim when I was like
24 yeah in like 80 was like 80 out of
100 times I submitted myself to be a
maxim hometown hottie like please pick
me please pick me and then yeah I didn't
you have the greatest personality of
anyone you think people are just so
fascinated with you on Loni life though
they're fascinated by the fact that John
and I are two incredibly different
people and his tweet will be like so
serious and so whether it's devastating
or impactful mine will always be so
stupid so I think people love your
honesty though have you ever hesitated
cuz I've done this where I write
something and I'm like oh god I'll
delete well now I mean I used to be
insane on Twitter but but now I
definitely think about it and I think
about the way it would be presented and
I asked John like do you think this is a
good idea and sometimes he'll say if you
believe it then it's fine but if it's
gonna you know I really affect you after
then maybe try to hold back but with
celebrities like it's good to just
apologize for being
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I think like I think it's very possible
to do a very human-like apology and say
like wow I'm so sorry that I was this
dumb in this moment I didn't think about
this person that person this person my
mistake I'm gonna learn from this and
we're gonna move on I think more people
need to do that and it's not instead of
like I'm sorry I hurt you people do like
to talk about the harm of social media a
lot but scrolling through your posts I
just see all the good that it can do for
example it can show people how to be
patient parents look at this video of
Christie negotiating with Luna which I
think all of us moms and dads can relate
I now call to order the meeting of the
candy first off Luna I would like you to
speak tell me about why you deserve the
candy and I think Kenny cuz I'm learning
what are you going to do if I give you
the candies no I mean are you gonna be
good yeah how about let's go into
negotiations now how about how many
pieces of candy how many pieces of candy
I say one what do you say I say like
three that's a good negotiator all right
what about one yeah I went to me I just
love John egging Ron John's like that's
reasonable I'm sorry but sexiest man
alive isn't above this was perfect for
things he's not above performing while
drunk either and I love that you video
this this is my favorite thing you've
ever done this happened just last month
[Music]
[Applause]
like I saw oz was having a sale on
Wednesdays I was like what's there $7
let's get onesies and so we got the
onesies then we decided to go to
Universal and then I said let's go
incognito and wear these onesies and no
one will know who we are and John picked
the one with his face on it found a
onesie minutes face on it that's all
yeah hater Lee says I love John Legend
in his face we were like no one will
know who we are
he's completely MC hammered but the
initial thought behind this was that the
stage was empty so I thought it'd be
funny of Chonga on stage and I filmed
him performing to nobody and then a
second he had to know everyone flooded
over so it was not meant to be a nice
thing okay just a little bit some of you
have been around since my very first
tiny tiny website it was like a
wordpress blog I updated it from my
phone I've been wanting to do a real
website where it was a true community of
people that love cravings love the
cookbooks love the cookware just a place
where you can see everything that is our
family we wanted to share everything in
one little spot for you guys by Luna
[Applause]
she just launched her new website and
the fan collection for her cravings line
which I love I actually asked it I think
you don't feel any pressure to post
anything because I just wanted people to
have it and sometimes I'm like oh my god
they think I want them to post it and
I'm so mortified no I didn't get your
basket too late in the game because we
had been in Tennessee so I had already
bought today Target like I do that my
whole buggy but here's the front of you
right after you you launched your
website so what's what's happening here
oh yeah this is me working the controls
just casually no we crashed which is a
which is amazing because I posted it on
Twitter on Instagram at the same time
because I'm stupid many people post on
Twitter and Instagram at the same time I
was like everybody's blood my website
and then they did and it's it's honestly
it was incredible it was awesome because
it's such a true labor of love that we
were so happy to do it for everybody and
I've never had a website except for like
a tiny little blog in the very very
beginning of john and i's dating life
and and and then this is just transform
into a team but also very personal to me
so i love it it's very inclusive so why
did you want to create a website since
you're already on social media level
because twitter is one thing instagrams
one another thing and then having a
community where there's people that have
enjoy the same things as you is very
different so there's twitter where you
are basically attacked a lot yeah I have
a heavy filters on me did you not hear
that John and I run Christmas no I know
Sharon Osbourne man she hates you guys
on my show and I was like wait what I
was like people got so mad because we
changed but he had this idea because
they need to move it they pulled baby
it's cold outside from any radio like a
lot of radio stations at Christmas well
I love that so yeah but then share
assume that you guys burned them all in
the backyard or something they can never
listen to the original Idol again and
both John and I've actually cut baby
it's cold outside the original and we
like the original but we noticed that a
lot of people didn't so we're like oh
let's just give him another option or
whatever and apparently we killed
Christmas nice I mean I literally woke
up the next day and I was like I can't
have my creepy song it's not the
date-rape dream baby song I was like
honestly the original doesn't even
offend me I just was like cool we'll do
another version exactly yeah like I'm
not offended like I hear it all hard to
offend me I wasn't mad about the song I
don't care what you guys are there to be
like oh I hate this now oh my god ghetto
yeah it's so weird
yeah she actually said and she means it
like she loves y'all that's why I
thought was still weird like she took it
so personal like I just thought it was
weird like but but here's the thing I
actually love her I do I she came on
here and I was like I love her I think
she's so funny but then I was like we
didn't kill Christmas either nice or
lying well cuz I'm trying to understand
it because I'm like there are so many
issues in the world right now I mean no
like a high creepy song like it's so
weird anyway you go of your holiday
table though and I really want to know
this did you make all that oh you know
what okay so this I posted so that's a
high single dish on this table I've
actually made for Thanksgiving and many
many times I've never made this many at
once I wanted to show people everything
so that they could be able to piece
together their menu and picture to go
out yes yes and it was important to me
that it wasn't like all edited together
I wanted to shoot them all together and
then we ate posts all at the end of the
night so I had that eat the burlap it's
so nice yeah like I'm very proud of it
alright so what's new because I already
have most your
what's say in your collection so I have
this Dutch oven which is to me is like
super super easy I do a lot of soups and
stews this tagine is my prized
possession because this cool is inspired
by many trips to Morocco and this shape
here ensures that moisture like
distributes evenly within the pot and
you can transfer it from oven to
stovetop or stovetop to oven okay and
everything's super super tender after I
want you to teach me how to cook oh I
would love to I don't could we just wear
robes at my house yes I will do it I
only hang out with people that don't
want to get dressed up I don't think
I've ever seen photos of you out I don't
like that well it's a little different
like our personalities are very similar
we are so similar I'm team Kelly okay
thank you what is that the wall and this
um and this stainless steel walk is my
profit honestly to me this is such a
beautiful gift which is why I thought
I'd be the perfect audience member gift
so which is why we are giving it to
everybody
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this